[Musique]
économiser l'énergie où en trouver de
nouvelles sources va donc rester un mot
d'ordre pour longtemps économie énergie
écologie sont d'ailleurs des mots qui ne
font pas que rim et ensemble ils
deviennent inséparables
tout le monde a bien conscience et on ne
compte plus les inventeurs qui travaille
dans cette direction
on a vu on en a vu beaucoup d'ailleurs
de ses inventeurs travailler sur des
économiseurs qui n'ont pu être
exploitées pour la plupart on en a vu
d'autres découvrir de nouveaux
carburants qui faisait long feu or avec
notre confrère l'auto journal
nous avons suivi de très près une
expérience qui est sans doute plus
intéressante que les autres un inventeur
henry repli ce berger déjà détenteur de
quarante trois brevets sur les moteurs
ce n'est pas n'importe qui travaille
depuis quelques années sur un procédé
qui fait rêver tout le monde
le carburant sans pétrole le carburant
fabriqué à partir d'une botte de paille
deux fois ou n'importe quel réseau du
végétal au début on a pris ça pour un
canular
et aujourd'hui les laboratoires d'une
grande compagnie pétrolière s'intéresse
à cette découverte
une table ronde a été organisée avec un
représentant de l' agence pour les
économies d'énergie
mélanger avec de l'essence ce liquide
tiré d'une botte de paille fait rouler
normalement une voiture évidemment ça
pose beaucoup de questions beaucoup de
vérifications
michel chevalet s'est rendu dans le
laboratoire de monsieur reprise berger
ou plutôt autour de son alambic de
campagne voici pour l'instant les
conclusions de michel chevalet une villa
à beaulieu sur mer à flanc de colline
sur la terrasse une étrange
installations que ne renierait pas du
bout un autoclave et un alambic mais on
fait avec un vieux fûts d'huile et
pourtant cela marche au fond l'inventeur
monsieur reprise berger devant nos
caméras avec deux kilos de failles il va
nous fabriquer en quatre heures de temps
un quart de litre de son carburant qui
est en fait un alcool
l'iso propanolol première opération met
dans l'autoclave cilic d'eau additionnée
de 150 g de bicarbonate de soude et ont
fait mijoter le tout 45 minutes à 120 de
greffe
ce n'est plus de la cuisine mais ce
n'est pas encore de la chine après avoir
rincé le tout on ajoute deux litres
d'eau et 100 g d'isopropyle had
d'aluminé en chauffe 45 minutes entre
160 et 170 degrés reste enfin la
troisième opération qui n'est rien
d'autre qu'une fermentation qu'est ce
que c'est clairement quels secrets et
alors j'ajoute encore un peu de cobalt
c'est fini votre invention qu'est que
vous savez fabriquer facilement cet
alcool à partir de produits végétaux
c'est ça et puis aussi le prix de
revient
le carburant hr revient à moins de 0 50
centimes du litre toutes taxes comprises
alors que l'essence tel vous l'avez à la
pompe
elle revient à 0 62 quelle est la
proportion que vous mettez dans les
boîtes une abeille 35% ses bons 40 aussi
si on veut
en fait
c'est de l'alcool
à les écouter la mana voilà je sais que
michel chevrel à goûter et puis ensuite
eh bien ça a marché dans un moteur
[Musique]